字幕: Maki Sugimoto
校正: Yuko Shirakawa
こんにちは
これは僕の小さい時の写真です
僕は昔から冒険好きで
三輪車でどこかへ行ったり
新しい道を見つけては
友達と二人で
冒険に行ったりしてました
そこで見つけたレンガを
ひっくり返して
ダンゴムシを持って帰ってきて
お母さんに怒られたりしてました
たまに冒険好きが先走ってしまって
こうやって泣いて帰ってきたり
するんですけどね
僕はこんな幼少時代を過ごしました
小中高に上がっても
身体は大きくなるんですけど
やっぱ冒険好きは変わらなくって
小中高って12年間
親友がいたんですね
そいつといつも二人で
冒険に行ってました
その時の会話は
こんな感じです
僕が「〇〇行かへん？」って
言うんですよ
そしたら親友が
「ええなぁ
そしたら何々して
道はどこどこ通って
お菓子はどこどこで買って
何々して何々して」
「ええやん」って
言うんですよ 僕
皆さん ここで気付いて
欲しいんですけど
僕 最初と最後の二言しか
言ってないんですね
（笑）
「行かへん？」と「ええやん！」
だけしか言ってないんですよ
あとは全部 親友が
やってくれたんです
僕 ずっと こうやって
12年間 冒険を続けてきました
大学に入ってこいつと
離れ離れになってしまったんです
どうしよう これから一人で
冒険しなあかんな と思ってたら
新しい親友を見つけました
（笑）
その時の会話は こんな感じです
「ねえ 〇〇行かない？」
「いいね！　そしたら何々して
道はどこどこ通って
ご飯どこで食べて
宿はどこどこ取って
何々して何々して」
「いいね！」って言うんですよ
（笑）
皆さん どこが変わったか
分かりますか これ？
僕が関西弁から
標準語に変わってます
（笑）
でも それが変わっただけで
あとは何も変わって
いないんです やっぱり
僕は相変わらず
最初と最後の二言だけ言って
あとは親友がやってくれたんですね
そういう冒険を
大学でもしてました
ある日僕「ねえ 日本縦断行かない？」
って言ったんですよ
今度は親友が「お おう」
みたいな感じで
ちょっと日本縦断って
大きかったのか
ちょっと反応が
鈍かったんですね
でも いつも僕は冒険の話を
だしたら行けると思ってますから
すごいワクワクしてたんですよ
親友から返ってきた言葉が
「そしたら-
行かない！」って
言われたんですよ
僕「えっ？」って
なるわけですよ
いつも 最初と最後の
二言さえ言えば
行けると思ってましたから
「え なんでやねん？」って
思ったんです
多分さすがに日本縦断って
大きかったんだと思います
親友にとっても
でも僕 ワクワクしてますから
すごい行きたかったんです
だからいつも二人で
行ってた冒険を
一人で行かないと
ダメになったんですね
その時に 僕の前に
「日本縦断」という
大きな壁が現れたんです
どうしようかなって思ってたら
まず先輩に相談したんです
先輩に相談したら 先輩が
「野口 いつも二人で行ってた
冒険に 一人で行って
殻をぶち破るチャンス
じゃないか？」
て言ってくれたんです
「あ 確かに」と思ったんですけど
いつも親友に任せてたんで
一人で何もできなかったんですよ
だから すっごく
ワクワクしてたけど
今回はナシかな
諦めようかなってした時に
お父さんのことが
パッと思い浮かんだんですよ
お父さんの言葉っていうのが
「大志 人生 生きてたら
何とかなるぞ」
って言うんです
お父さん 適当でよく
「何とかなる 何とかなる」
って言うんですよ
その言葉で人生 何回か
救われたことがあるんですけど
その言葉がパッと
思い浮かんだんですね
そしたら「今回も何とか
なるんちゃうかな？」って思ったんです
何とかなると思った
僕はそこから
「よっしゃ 何とかなるやろ
行ったれ」と思って
日本縦断へ出発したんです
"初めてのお使い"ならぬ
"初めての一人旅"に行ったんですね
その時の様子が こんな感じです
（笑）
無謀にも冬に原付[バイク]で
一人で行きました
（笑）
半径10kmの地図も
読めないような僕が
冬に一人で原付で
日本縦断に出発したんです
一日目 半径10kmの地図も
読めないような僕が
(鹿児島県）鹿屋市から300km離れた
大分県別府市まで行けたんです
地図は読めなかったんですけど
人に聞いたりして
何とか行けたんですね
その時に 宿を探そうと思ったら
僕 宿取れない ってことになって
無謀にも公園に
テントを張って寝たんです
その時はビクビクしながら
寝てたんですけど
でも一日目が終わって
二日目の朝 パッと起きた時に
「あれ？ 案外イケてるやん」
って思ったんです
何とかなってるやんって
思ったんですね
その時に自分の前にあった
大きな壁が無くなって
現実の壁が現れた
気がしたんです
そこに手が届いた
気がしたんですね
もう壁の上に手が届いた僕は
そこからトントン拍子でした
地図が読めるようになるし
チケットも取れるようになる
宿も取れるようになる
そして日本縦断 達成したんですよ！
僕 壁乗り越えたんですね
パッと振り返ってみた時に
あんなに大きいと思ってた壁は
イメージや思い込みで
現実の壁ってこんな小さい壁だったなぁ
って思ったんです
こうやって壁を乗り越えた
経験をした僕は
次もチャレンジするわけですよ
次は一人でカナダ留学に行きました
カナダ留学というと外国なんで
やっぱり大きな壁だったんです
しかも今回はプラスアルファ
大学のテストと
丸かぶりだったんですよ
普通は大学のテストを優先させて
カナダは延期すると思うんですけど
僕は今回も何とか
なるやろと思って
先生全員に 直訴しに
行ったんです
「追試にして下さい！」って
言いに行ったんです
そしたら全員に 「追試ＯＫです」って
そしてカナダ留学も達成しました
また前にあった大きな壁は
無くなって
今回の壁 ぴょ―んと
飛び越えられた気がしたんですね
（笑）
やっぱり振り返ってみると
あんなに大きいと思ってた壁は
こんな小さい壁だったんだ
なあって思ったんです
こうやって乗り越えた僕は
また次チャレンジするわけですよ
次のチャレンジっていうのが
まさに今です
今 僕 こうやって
TEDxの舞台に立っています
TEDって大好きで
いつも観てたんですけど
すごいアイディアを持った
人たちが話すなあって思ってたんです
いつかあの舞台に立ちたいけど
夢みたいな日だなって
思ってたんです
すっごい大きな壁が
僕の前にあったんですね
でも今回も 何とかなる精神で
チャレンジしてみたんです
そしたら 皆さん今僕
何とかなっていますよね？
（笑）（拍手）
ありがとうございます！
今 壁の上に 手が届きました
まだ乗り越えてないので
振り返ることはできないんですけど
こうやって壁の上に
手がかかった 今
今回も乗り越えられそうな気がします
こうやって乗り越えた後に
振り返ってみると
あんなに大きいと
思ってた壁は
こんな小さい壁だったんだなって
また思うと思います
皆さんも今 自分の中に
大きな壁ってありますよね？
例えば 好きな人に告白するとか
新しい仕事を始めるとか
でもそれって 思い込みなんです
思い込みで大きいと
思ってるんです
どうせ思い込むんなら
何とかなると 思い込んでみてください
そうしたら意外と 一歩目が
すっと出たりします
一歩目が出ると 壁の上に手が届くと
もうこっちのものです
あとは トントン拍子
乗り越えて 振り返ってみた時に
あんなに大きいと思ってた壁は
こんなに小さい壁だったなって
思うと思います
そうやって乗り越えた
経験をした人は
次にもチャレンジしやすいんです
そうやってどんどん壁を
乗り越えていって
自分の世界を広げていってください
僕はこの「何とかなる」って言葉
わが家の家訓にしようと思っています（笑）
まだ奥さんも子供も
いないですけど
そして今日この言葉をくれた父に
この場で感謝を送りたいと思います
今日は母の日ですけど
僕は父に送ります
ありがとうございました